comprar una casa un coche una
hamburguesa en el salvador desde hace un
mes todas estas transacciones se pueden
hacer con el bitcoin la ley establece
que cualquier agente económico tiene que
aceptar esta cripto moneda como medio de
pago junto con el dólar estadounidense
moneda oficial del servidor desde 2001
yo lo veo como una oportunidad para mi
negocio para incrementar mis ventas y
así darle opciones a mis clientes esto
es emocionante porque es la primera vez
creo probablemente en la historia que el
salvador ha sido realmente capaz de
liderar el mundo en algo pero no todos
los salvadoreños comparten este
entusiasmo la principal fuente de
desconfianza es la volatilidad de la
cripto moneda de hecho su adopción
desató una ola de especulación
financiera en el país cerca de la mitad
de los salvadoreños no tienen acceso a
internet por ende garantizar el uso del
monedero electrónico oficial conocido
como chivo resulta difícil el uso del
bit coin
en los negocios ha sido bastante
reducido para la magnitud del subsidio
que se entregó
y en ese sentido todavía no tenemos la
claridad de cuáles son los beneficios
que esperaba recibir el gobierno verdad
en el país solía haber 200 cajeros
automáticos de chivo pero uno fue
quemado en una de las múltiples
protestas contra la adopción del bitcoin
que puntuaron en el mes de septiembre la
ambiciosa y polémica reforma monetaria
fue impulsada por el presidente en allí
bukele quien asegura que cerca de una
tercera parte de los 6.4 millones de
salvadoreños son usuarios de chivo el
bitcoin es también promovido como una
manera de reducir el pago de tarifas a
la hora de recibir remesas que
representan más del 20 por ciento del
pib salvadoreño